having just done this question okay you
want to be able to anticipate on what
about this question because you
basically got the same thing but upside
down okay but still let's go into it
slowly all right now get your ruler out
this is all we know where the first
derivative okay
so and these two points here the roots
right okay
those are going to be stationary points
in the graph above yes okay so let's put
our robot
okay so far so good right now
before I go up I'm gonna go down because
actually do war number one it's easier
as you saw number two actually what we
see down here will help us to graph
what's above okay so for instance on
this graph I have a the derivative has a
stationary point does that make sense
look this graph this graph has a
stationary point there make sense so
what that should correspond to is a root
down here okay
now pay attention to them our gradient
here right it's increasing and then it's
decreasing the increasing increasing
increasing and then decreasing okay so
this is a parabola we're expecting some
kind of straight line down here but
since this should be positive going to
negative it's going to be going
downwards
okay now this is important for us
because as we go up to this graph right
I'm expecting two stationary points okay
but see this is a bit like the turning
the nature of a stationary point here
this information now here is telling us
the left-hand stationary point should be
concave up because the second derivative
is positive so this stationary point up
here is going to be facing up okay so
it's a minimum okay this is a minimum in
the same way or rather in the opposite
way this one will be a max okay so that
tells me if this is going to be a
minimum and this is going to be a
maximum that tells me something about
their relative location okay
you can't have a minimum above a max
because then it wouldn't be a minimum
right it would be a max right so
therefore the Minoru I don't know where
it's gonna be vertically it could be
anywhere let me just put it there
okay I've drawn a horizontal line as a
stationary point the max must be above
it right so something like that
now again cuz I don't know any scales uh
this could be all up above or it could
be you know closer together or further
apart I don't know I'm still getting the
general shape okay so to join these two
again I'm gonna be expecting right in
the middle there should be a point of
inflection yes so something like this
okay and the rest of the graph well
let's have a look
on the right hand side here the graph
the derivative is negative so I'm
dropping as you would expect any good
cubic to do and over here right again
the first derivative is negative okay so
that's why this is also dropping okay
now in terms of the roots like these
things here they could be anywhere the
things were paying attention to other
critical points where are the stationary
points which way do they turn where's
the point of inflection okay